VENKATESH RAMASWAMY:
Hi, everyone.
Welcome to a talk on switching
from DynamoDB to Cloud Bigtable
and Cloud Spanner.
We had a lot of
learnings, and we
had a lot of fun
when we ended up
migrating from AWS
to Google Cloud,
and we'd like to share
our experiences with you.
My name is Venkatesh Ramaswamy.
I work for ShareChat
and my copresenter
is Vishal Parpia, who
works for Cloudcover.
We've talked a little bit
about who we are and what we do
and fundamental
reasons as to why
you would choose
a migration, some
of the choice of
database and decisions
that we ended up going through.
Some of the key design and
architectural principles
as well.
Some of the details around
data migration, batch,
and stream processing
will also be discussed.
We will delve a little bit
on performance and audit
and why those are
important, and finally,
end up with some
of the learnings
that we had through the process.
A little bit on who
we are and what we do.
Let me talk about ShareChat,
the company that I work for.
We were founded in 2015, and
our latest series D funding
was led by Twitter
in August of 2019.
We are India's home grown, and
one of the largest social media
platforms out there,
where we don't
offer English as an option.
As of latest, we have about
150 million active users
on our website.
We exist because there is
a fundamental disconnect
between the choice that
a lot of users in India
want versus what's
available out there.
If you see the users in tier
2 and tier 3 series in India,
a lot of them are not
comfortable in conversing
in English because that's
not their native language,
so we give them the
language of their choice
that they could use
to end up interacting,
conversing, and
sharing social media
posts with people around it.
Very recently, we launched
Moj, a short video
app that we will spend a
little bit of limelight
towards the end of
this presentation.
I'll now hand it over
to Vishal to talk
about him and his company.
VISHAL PARPIA:
Thanks, Venkatesh.
I'm Vishal.
I'm the CEO and co-founder
for a Cloudcover.
We are a premier partner
with Google Cloud,
and we specialize in moving
companies like ShareChat
from one cloud to the other,
or from their data center
to the cloud.
Our core focus is on agile
enterprises and scale startups,
and we use a lot
of new technology,
including cloud
native tech, in order
to make that happen with
DevOps and data engineering.
So I'm going to
talk specifically
about what we did with
ShareChat, and at a very
high level, it always
looks really easy.
On both AWS and Google
Cloud, you effectively
have an app, a service,
and a database.
But as we all know, the
devil is in the details,
and I'm going to hand
it back to Venkatesh
to give you a little
bit of insight
as to the unique
challenges that we faced
in this particular migration.
VENKATESH RAMASWAMY:
Thanks, Vishal.
As we are now
looking at what you
need to do when you move from
one cloud system to the other,
you have to look at the
fundamental challenges
that you would encounter.
In our case, we
were on ECS, and we
wanted to be completely
on GKE when we would
finish the migration process.
CloudWatch was our choice for
all the logging and monitoring
on AWS.
On Google, it will have
to be Stackdriver logging
and monitoring,
with the key note
that we would need 100% of
it to be available on day one
for all observability
requirements.
On AWS, we were completely
on Elastic cache
using Redis as a storage engine.
On Google Cloud, we
would want to end up
being on Managed Redis,
and even though they
were sort of almost
the same company,
it is not exactly
apples to apples,
and that's something that
we had to contend with.
Now, data migration
is a very key piece
of the entire process,
and we were sure
that we had to meet
100% of our data
even when a single user
had to be migrated over
from AWS to Google Cloud.
Ultimately, we needed a
service mesh integration
to get better insights
into service dependencies,
and we had to do all of
this with zero downtime.
When you start the migration
and get through the process,
it's like drinking
from a firehose.
We hope to share with you
some of our key learnings,
some of our key challenges,
through the next set of slides
to make sure that you are
not in the same situation,
and you do a much better
job with all the learnings
and challenges that
we ended up with.
So let's fundamentally
ask ourselves,
why should we migrate?
Let me walk you through some
of the thoughts that we had,
which started at around
middle of last year,
where we were hitting
limitations of scale
with DynamoDB.
Now, we partially solved
them through the use of DAX,
but they were just
not good enough.
We were still hitting a lot of
challenges during peak times,
so when we ended up looking
deeper into what we had to do,
we came to the conclusion
along with consultation
from AWS that we had to rewrite
a lot of our key and core
systems.
Now, in that situation,
we wondered, was there
another option?
Was there something we
could do from the ground up?
And should we look at moving
to another cloud provider
when, ultimately, the set of
changes that we needed to do
were pretty dramatic
to begin with?
The other key factor was
that we had to save costs,
and this was extremely important
given the kind of scale
and the kind of
traffic that we had.
We also were looking for a
very key and strategic partner
for our long term set of
challenges that we would
ultimately end up
in [INAUDIBLE],,
and we had very unique use cases
that we were encountering month
after month.
Ultimately, we needed a
platform for innovation,
and that's why we
looked across the board,
and Google Cloud came out
tops in our evaluation
as to the platform of choice.
Let me give you a
little bit of the stats
and go over some of the key
stats on our existing system
using DynamoDB.
We had a total of about
200 in all tables that we
had to migrate and about
80 terabytes of data.
As an example, a single
table had close to what 17
secondary indexes--
obviously not extremely
optimized, but something
that we had to account for when
we end up doing the migration.
At peak, our total read units
were at about five million QPS,
and that was a lot of data that
we had to contain and make sure
that we don't take a hit.
And ultimately, our
read and write agencies
were at the order of
about six milliseconds,
and that's a very
critical number
that we could not compromise on.
Let's start with the choice
of databases, and ultimately,
here's [INAUDIBLE].
For any migration,
you have to make sure
that the data considerations
are taken care of from day one.
You solve for the
data, and I can almost
guarantee that the bulk of your
problems and your pain points
will be automatically
taken care of.
So there's one learning that you
want to take away, it probably
is that.
Now, we had a polyglot
setup in our systems.
We had a lot of DynamoDB, a
lot of Redis, Mongo, Cassandra,
Elastic, S3-- you
name it, we had it.
And we also needed a
NoSQL that would support
secondary indexes, so we had
fundamentally four choices
that we could end
up choosing from.
Choice number one, we could
go with a single cloud managed
database.
Life is easy, and you could just
make one choice and move on.
Choice number two, we could
still make a single choice,
but this time, we would choose
a self managed database,
completely to be taken
care of from our end.
Choice number three would
be a hybrid solution,
but optimized for cost, and
ultimately, the fourth choice
would be another hybrid
solution but optimized
for long-term [INAUDIBLE].
Looking at option
one and option two,
it's a very clear choice between
choosing a single database
that's provided by cloud,
that's cloud native, which
is very easy to migrate,
but would be extremely
complex for some use
cases where you don't
need all that functionality.
Or would you want to go self
managed, where you would take
on the burden of maintaining
all the different databases
[INAUDIBLE] experts?
But now, in my opinion, a
self managed database actually
nullifies the impact
and the benefits
of why you would actually
choose one in the first place.
It's useful for a
lot of situations,
but not in our use case.
If you look at option 3, one
of the things we could do
was put all our index and
secondary index needs,
we could choose and
store them in a database
that actually supported that.
In this case, that
would be Cloud Spanner.
And all the raw data, the
data on the leaf nodes,
notes, we could store
it in a database that
didn't require any special
indexing requirements, which
would be Cloud Bigtable.
So the data in a
single table would
be split across two tables.
This would make reads and
writes a little interesting,
and would require applications
or at least a layer
to handle those reads
and writes interestingly
on the app side of things
instead of the database
side of things.
Let's look at option
4, which is ultimately
what we ended up choosing.
This is getting the database
to do what it's really good at.
So we ended up using
Cloud Bigtable for all
our single index
database requirements,
table requirements and
storage requirements.
And we used Cloud Spanner
for all the requirements
where you needed more
than a single index.
So this allowed us to end up
using the database for what
it was built for, for
what it was really good at
and taking and moving the burden
from the application owners
to the databases and
leveraging them for what
they are really good at.
To talk a little bit about the
key design and architecture
principles, for that, I want
to have Vishal come and spend
some time.
VISHAL PARPIA:
Thanks, Venkatesh.
So after we help ShareChat
out to figure out
which options worked best
for their specific use case,
we had to then get
into the actual design
of how we would make these
work and how we would actually
enact the migration itself.
The concept that made
sense for us over here,
was to use a data
abstraction layer.
Now a data abstraction layer is
a fairly common design pattern
in software engineering.
And it also takes the guise of
something like a middleware.
In the case of ShareChat, they
were already using libraries
internally to kind of
obfuscate DynamoDB and provide
that functionality
to the application.
So we wanted to take
advantage of that.
The traditional approach would
have had the data abstraction
layer live inside of service.
So literally inside the code.
But because we were
moving to Kubernetes,
we had the opportunity of
using a sidecar approach
to make the same thing happen.
And this gave us a few
really key benefits
that we would have otherwise
not been able to get.
This modified sidecar
approach effectively
took the shape of
a database driver
that ran as a sidecar
process and allowed
us to do things like
connection pooling for the pod.
We were also able to
do a single driver
for multiple different
kinds of languages
and just have a different
library that would
interact with it over GRPC.
And this obviously gave us a
dramatic performance increase
in terms of the
kind of code that we
were running, because we
wrote everything in Go.
And it also allows
us to, in the future,
potentially change the
database redirections.
And this pattern worked so
well, that we are actually
going to open source
this with Google as well.
The critical piece
over here though,
was that ShareChat
didn't need to change
anything inside their
application layer at all.
They just need to swap out
the library that was being
used to access the database.
And this gave us
an enormous benefit
in terms of the speed with
which we could actually
make this migration occur.
So I'm going to talk about
that migration in a little bit
more detail.
This was obviously a
fairly gargantuan task.
As you saw with the early slides
that Venkatesh showed you,
we were talking about
a substantial number
of both tables, as well as data.
And in order for us to
be able to move this over
from AWS to Google in a
repeatable and reliable manner,
we had to use a
multi-stage process.
So the three phases that we
ended up with effectively
looked like this.
We had a starting with a batch
of an upload of all of the data
until a specific point in time.
And at the moment
that we actually
started that dump of
data from DynamoDB,
we also started inserting
all the mutations
that occurred to the
DynamoDB tables into Pub/Sub.
We were going to use that
in T1, which was basically
after we were done
with the load,
we wanted to be able to play
back all the changes that
happened to the database
after we had loaded
that point in time snapshot.
Following that, and this
is the most crucial phase,
when we were actually
sort of in sync,
we wanted to be able to
start streaming data directly
from AWS to Google.
And this was probably one of
the most complicated parts
of the entire system,
because we couldn't
use Pub/Sub to do this.
We had to build our
own system to enable
that kind of streaming
from DynamoDB
directly into both Cloud
Bigtable and Cloud Spanner.
So let's talk about
the batch processing.
So we took exports
of the table data
from DynamoDB, which
ended up inside S3.
And we would basically
watch and consume those
and stuff them into
an SQS queue that
would be process by
EC2 instances that
would both compress and
transfer that over to GCS.
On the Google side, we
were watching and consuming
those buckets through
Cloud Functions that
were triggering individual
DAGs inside of Airflow, which
was running on Cloud Composer,
that would run on top
of dataflow multiple
jobs to both load data
into Cloud Spanner, as well as
Cloud Bigtable simultaneously.
And this, obviously,
was dependent
upon the configurations that
we had as to which table
went into which system
on the basis of where
the indexes were.
So all of the tables that had
multiple indexes would end up
in Cloud Spanner, and all the
tables that had single indexes
would end up in Cloud Bigtable
and give us better performance.
The load process itself was
also extremely complicated.
As you can imagine,
firstly, we're
trying to take data that's
inside a NoSQL system
and put it inside a SQL system
in the case of Cloud Spanner.
That required us to
actually add missing columns
when we detected them inside
the data that we were getting.
Because a lot of
this was legacy data,
they weren't very
stable schemas,
and taking advantage
of NoSQL allows
you to effectively create keys
and values as you see fit.
Well, that information
wasn't present
when we dumped the data in
some kind of format that
would allow us to create
the tables before we
did the transfer.
So we had to actually
do that on the fly.
So the code that we
wrote inside dataflow
would actually process all
of those individual rows
and add the appropriate tables,
column families, and missing
columns as required.
We also had a dead
letter pattern
that dealt with rejected records
and allowed us to retry them
after we had made the
appropriate changes
to either the data type
or the schema itself.
Once we were done with
that initial transfer,
we had to switch to doing
the stream processing.
This is where it started
getting really interesting.
So in order to make this happen,
we used the system on DynamoDB
called DynamoDB Streams.
Now what that does,
is it effectively
puts all the mutations
that are happening
inside DynamoDB into a
stream that can be consumed.
And it retains the data
for about 24 hours.
The lambda functions
that get triggered
on the back of that
had to be configured,
because it got really
expensive really fast.
So we set those up
so that they would
take batches of 10,000 records
in five minute intervals
and push those over
to some custom code
that we wrote on the
Google site running
on Compute Engine written in
golang that would allow us
to both push the
data in real time
into Cloud Spanner
and Cloud Bigtable,
depending upon
the configurations
that we had in place.
And this is really what
allowed us to do this.
We tried to use Pub/Sub and
there were multiple concerns
that we ran into with that.
Some of them were latency
related and some of them
were related to
ordering of the records
in order to make sure that it
was going into the database
systems at the right time.
As you can imagine,
latency and performance
is absolutely key over here.
And we actually built a whole
bunch of interesting code
to be able to manage any
kind of breaks that might
occur in the stream itself.
So after we were done
with that transfer,
it fell to our team to
make sure that Venkatesh
was happy with the outcome.
And that meant making sure
that the data actually
matched on both systems.
And that's where this comes in.
Venkatesh.
VENKATESH RAMASWAMY:
Thanks, Vishal.
Performance and audit
are two understated steps
in any migration process.
They never get due diligence.
And I want to talk a little
bit about what we did to end up
focusing on these two aspects.
So you always start
with data that's
publicly available, right?
It's great to have data
which is a starting point,
but you make sure
that you verify it.
So what we did was, to set up
a dummy setup in our staging
environment.
So in this example
that I have for you,
we had a 40 node cluster for
real table called tagPosts,
which was set up on Spanner,
which had about 160 GB of data
with about five indexes.
And we hammered it with a
readout ratio of a 4 to 1.
This allowed us to see how
this Spanner table actually
scaled with the amount of
traffic that it was getting,
and what was its breaking point.
And once you had that, the next
key part and the most important
part, is to try the
same in production.
And the reason for that
is, your physical setup
for staging and
production are going
to be fundamentally different.
And you do this and
you rinse and repeat
for most of the key
flows and the key tables
that you would expect
to hit a lot of traffic
during normal and
during peak times.
And this would give
you a lot of comfort
when you turn on the migration
step completely onto one side.
The two different
audit parts that
are important for any
migration, are one for streaming
and the other, which we'll
talk about in the next slide.
For streaming, it's extremely
important for us to make sure
that the data has been caught up
from the source and the system
output to the new system
that is under test.
In this case, AWS
was the source output
and Google Cloud would
be the system under test.
So the graph that we
have in front of you
was data that we
got from Influx,
which we were ending
up inserting into,
and visualized in Grafana.
So you see that initially
at time t equal 0,
you have about 18
to 19 hours of lag.
And ultimately, it takes
about six hours for the reader
to actually catch up and
get close down to 0 as well
as possible.
Again, you do this for your key
metrics, for your key tables.
And these are extremely
important to have
at your disposal to make sure
that your business metrics are
doing as well as
your system metrics.
Now looking at audit
for data consistency,
the way we did this was
to make sure that we
replayed the events that were
happening on AWS on Google
Cloud, and did a simple JSON
diff of the two response
objects that we got back.
And if there were
any differences,
we would end up logging that.
So the values that you
see here are real values
that we got when we initially
started out our migration
processes.
And this allowed us
to make sure that we
fixed this, we
take care of this,
we handled this before we
shift even the first user over.
And that gave us
the confidence to go
extremely confidently
to business and say,
you know what?
The system is as good
as the business metrics,
and we should not see any
perceptible impact on users
as they end up moving from
one system to the other.
And ultimately, I want to focus
a little bit on learnings.
But before that, I
want to start off
with a small story which
started at around the first week
of July, not too long ago, when
we launched our short video
app called Moj, which took just
about 30 hours from ideation
to the actual launch.
And guess what.
We were all ready.
Google Cloud was ready
for us in terms of scale,
in terms of the kind of
traffic that we were expecting.
Around the same time, because
of geopolitical reasons,
our traffic on the ShareChat
app also went astronomical.
We went to almost
3x, 4x amount of data
that we were typically used to.
And we didn't even blink an eye.
We were able to horizontally
scale with zero to minimal code
changes.
Close enough for about
a week from then,
we made the decision to
move all of the traffic
for Moj, which was quite
a bit, on to Singapore.
And all this really happened
behind the scenes seamlessly,
thanks to the amazing
support from Google
that we ended up receiving.
Care for minimal changes that
we had to do on the DNS entries,
we really didn't have much
in terms of challenges
that we faced during
that shift over.
And ultimately, it's
kudos to everybody
who has been involved in this.
And I wanted to use this as the
poster child for the benefits
that we have gotten just three
months after the migration
process.
And ultimately, the
learnings from the migration
itself, I think it's
important to know
that the migration or any
migration of this nature
is not going to
be a linear path.
You could plan for
all you want, you
could build on the
contingencies in place,
you would still end
up encountering things
of the unknown nature.
And you just have to
fight your way through it.
But what's very
key and important
is the top down ownership
and the commitment
that you need to have to
make sure to get through all
these challenges
that come you way
and sign up for long weekends
and nights that will ultimately
be the outcome.
Solve your DB choices first.
Extremely important.
I've mentioned this before.
I'm going to keep
mentioning this.
Your data is going to be
the ultimate decider of how
good your migration process is.
Your data doesn't
get moved correctly,
you can have a
number of challenges,
even with all the
computes in place, even
with all the scalable inputs.
And then ultimately,
separate out your migration
and your optimization tasks.
A lot of the people
want to end up
doing one step of the
migration process,
then ending up putting
an optimization
step on top of that.
It doesn't work very well.
In fact, it's chaotic.
It's extremely disastrous.
We didn't do it
and we would never
do it, even if we had to
redo this all over again.
There's a lot of learnings.
But the key part is,
separate them out.
Make sure that you
focus on the migration.
If you have cost
concerns, talk to Google,
talk to your cloud provider.
I'm sure they'll have a
path forward for you guys.
And ultimately, work as
a single team, folks.
I can say this enough.
We had a lot of different
parties associated with this.
We had developers, we
had a Google PSO team,
we had actual Google engineers
from Spanner, from Bigtable,
from code engineering teams.
We had our set of consultants.
We had CloudCover, who
was our partner in crime.
And we worked as a
single unit, which
means that if I had
feedback to give,
I would not just
give it to my folks,
I would give it to everybody.
So finally, I want to thank
all of these people involved.
An amazing set of aligned
work, amazingly focused
set of people that were
involved in this process.
It would be impossible to end
up thanking everybody that
made this possible,
but I still want
to give out my heartfelt
thanks from both me and Vishal
for making this a reality.
Thank you, folks, thank
you for everything.